I know you are both an actress we know
you for films like your faustino and the
world is that nothing many more besides
that you're a producer as well how do
you marry those two professions it's
very very easy now you kill the actress
and you can with a producer now it's
nice to be a producer when you have a
talent like Federico because it's easy
because they are sure about the success
what makes toolpath the film is your
fright fest with stand out from other
horror films it's different you will see
the difference and I'm curious to see
the audience reaction because this is
not just a horror film is a more exact
illogical trailer and is more about
sensibilities is a great musician in the
ears a great Sensibility so it knows
very very well out to to pull out your
your your fear from inside and you know
and to make you feel the fear so you
will see now what scourge you most about
the film when you are either reading the
script or seeing it filmed you know is
that I felt I felt very very good when I
read the script and they felt very very
scared when I saw the film with the
particular moments in the film that
stood out for you that really scared you
you know they think that it is that
everything is so real that can happen to
you in any moment over your life
you